on october eleventh two thousand twelve
film courage attended a press roundtable
interview with actress and hache for the
film that's what she said for more
information on the film please visit
that's what she said movie.com for more
videos and articles on empowering actors
filmmakers and other creatives please
visit film courage calm you got a big
response I'm really happy to hear it
glad we are relating to people i think
that's one of the things that's
refreshing no I wanted to ask you the
film is I believed in here so I
understand there that there's because
our relationships can develop and
there's a magnum almost a magnet for
people who come together and never even
that would never come together yes and I
wanted to ask you you know tell us how
that works how mean how you know how you
guys work together to build those
bizarre interchangeable but bonded
relationships well I think we all have
lived in New York so we knew I mean
there were a couple of things going on
one it was about where you get in New
York if you're single and you haven't
found a partner or maimed and how lonely
that is and how the city becomes an
obstacle to you that's really difficult
and then the other being new to the city
with
aliens character being so new and then
New York becomes this lease in a way
then you have to navigate it and
struggle is to overcome and we really
were all kind of friends brought
together my friends so Carrie really
thinks in believes this is a movie about
friendship I believe this is a movie
about finding friendship even in the
darkest hour and learning to you know
have faith even when you don't have it
and learning to trust that's my
characters during anything but we all
came together through different friends
Alec Baldwin called me told me that he
had to read this script he and i were in
20th century together with kelly over be
the writer I didn't tell oshiro he
thought I could pull off this character
you know I read it on my way to New York
I called you know instead letting me
carry before I get back home after doing
a letterman appearance I thought that
somebody who could play a hilarious sex
addict nymphomaniac was alia I had just
done see the rabbits with Allium so I
called her on the way back to the
airport by the time I got home she had
read it and said she was in so what is
that marcha de bonis of course was in
the play when it was done
Broadway nine years ago we were all
bonded through other friends or our own
friendship so and and like ah like odd
odd that i would know Ali a bizarre that
Alec Baldwin would be telling you Mike
Kelly over me script so in that was
truth already and that's the that's the
easiest kind of truth to them get on
camera because it's organic you said you
lived in New York count different where
your ex escapades in New York and the
character that you play most of my
escapades were getting my labrador dog
into the back of my car to drive to
brooklyn where i worked at avenue and
studio shooting a soap opera and
battling being a 17 18 year old playing
twins being afraid that I was going to
get fired because who wouldn't fire me I
had no idea what I was doing and driving
back to my waitressing job on the Upper
East Side that I had to back me up in
case i would get canned from the show
and in the world wow so mine was on the
triangle of my ridiculous life until
finally i was late enough setting up the
tables for my waitressing job soon
people at the restaurant were starting
to recognize that i was on a soap opera
and then I would be calling the studio
to say I can't I slept through my alarm
as I was working late last night they're
like wording but no bullets working
doing I was closing the bar at two
o'clock in the morning so finally I had
to quit that job but it was four years
of a soap opera which I was a soap opera
that's what my
Thanks were also looking for love also
battling the city but in different ways
of working an actress I think it's
easier looking for love now Cherie they
cast it for me yeah yeah wow that had
that man walked into the room awesome
he's cute i love him let's go there now
i have a baby doesn't that's got much
easier for me as i got older so a
challenge you most about being the role
yeah i'm going to go back for a moment
Annette the story about being playing
twins on another world and doing your
you're waitressing job was were you when
you got cast as on another world how
long and you said that was four years as
another world and four years that you
managed both a waitressing job oh no no
no the waitressing job went away in the
first year I was on another world for
four hours that's amazing that you would
maintain that and have that backup do
you do that off and have that plan B
just in case I do so many things right
now I i guess i do i've never seen it
quite this saying i have a back-up plan
but I guess I do it's so funny to put it
that way but I'm always doing a bunch of
different stuff and it may be that it is
out I mean my family it's no secret was
very very poor and I I don't want that
for my life or my children's life
against certainly but some might say I I
could relax a bit more and know that is
nice to have been doing I'm going to end
up in a car but I for better or worse I
love doing different things so you know
maybe my son black line is a backup to
my
yeah I don't think I made that but so
what challenge do you most about your 10
DD gosh i opened the script and there
was a girl who was hungover fell out of
bed gotta brushed her teeth while
smoking a cigarette and then I stopped I
was like what first of all I've never
read anything like that I thought that's
one of the most absurd things in the
world to actually describe a character
that way and taking action that way
because it's such punishment and such
self abuse and such addiction that you
that that that girl I mean it reads
funny so the challenges make all that
nasty stuff funny who is she you know
we've got it this is the beginning I
can't imagine where the script is going
to go but there's so much
self-destructiveness enough behavior
that i really had to go into some dark
what i felt needed to be really really
dark waters of a person who lost hope
who themselves and then make that funny
so that was it that was a pretty wild
beginning to to a character in a story
about you know redemption finding faith
in your
your friends being true to yourself when
you haven't been any good stuffing it
for how many years skini probably hasn't
told the truth about herself really
tough stuff and I'll i also thought
could be hilariously funny if I never
faltered from that self abuse and I
hadn't seen the place so I thought that
you develop that character from yourself
I didn't know that that character was
written into the script to be able oh I
didn't see the play either so i didn't
know i mean when i did 20th century I
didn't see Carol one heart doing either
it's not like I wasn't interested i just
i'd i wouldn't know i'm not comfortable
I think I'm so impressionable when I'm
open and being creative that I tend to
not have anything come in that might
because I'll just to drink it in and
become it so I wouldn't have wanted to
be influenced by that um the DD I mean
it's funny when I wanted out of foam and
say you know you can pull this off what
does that mean screw you buddy a lot of
drama addict is self-loathing um thanks
a lot I could've called me and asked me
to be his next romantically no use this
go get this movie name for our friends
but I do I take that as a genuinely Hugh
compliment because they think DD is a
very complicated woman that we don't get
to see very much because she's not
worried about it people like her or not
and we're in a world where every single
movie if it has a woman in it it's
usually wrapped around the woman wanting
to be liked in some way either in her
life or she's young she's Don janu she's
a hero she's the lover of somebody she's
the grandmother she's a chef she's you
know we always have these women they're
like somehow supposed to relate to in
these gorgeous motherly loving sexy ways
and I just wanted to strip all that away
and see what would see what would happen
and what I'm really in love with is that
people are finding they relate to it
because it's like watching yourself on
your worst day and I do it worse so you
can laugh at it what do you think
what
it's always a challenge to make an
independent film is always a challenge
to make a low-budget film so that being
said Carrie is the reason this movie got
me and she's the champion of it I don't
know it would not exist without her
belief and her stamina and her sacrifice
of everything including her bank account
to guarantee working with somebody like
that is inspiring and addicting you know
she's she's a ball of fire and she's
about as skinny as a twig and it's
really funny that she's got so much
energy and life and world and presents
around her I should I think she would
make anything happen I'm really really
proud of her for fighting so hard for
this movie because I think it's going to
turn her into the director she wants to
be with enough people seeing her work
that she'll be able to continue that as
career i know she wants to do that but
the challenges are your you know i said
we had to do all of our locations in
between times when people don't work in
New York so all of our scenes were about
10 pages long the barroom scene at the
end of the move
it was probably 15 pages long and we
would have to you know we were working a
stinky stinky cranky horrible bar that
we started a four o'clock in the morning
when it closed and had to end the scene
by four o'clock in the afternoon when it
had to open so we were rolling around
literally and beer and muck and mire for
about 10 days and and that was just one
scene the rest was the same it was a
trip it was hard it was hard work we
would arrive I remember alia saying to
me we were shooting in the coffee shop
was actually a piece of fatherly and we
came in in the morning and there were
stools at the pizza counter and he was
making the pizza sauce that they were
going to serve at the joint while I mean
his business needed to continue what we
were shooting which is in and of itself
hilarious and Ally there were no chairs
no makeup chairs or hair chairs there
was no like coffee spread nothing no for
this what doesn't exist and we showed up
and it was 4am as it was every day and
there were stools with no back and he
looked over and there was a tray of the
leftover Dorito packs from lunch the day
before breakfast and halle looked at me
and she's like man I told you I do
anything for you now but this might even
be pushing it it was it was a moment
there was one of our lows like wow I'm
so tired I can't even stand up on my
chair doesn't even have him back and I'm
smelling good looking for it was really
funny and of course we laughed about it
and she was joking but it was not
shoot you know I kept saying have we
hired the homeless to be our extras I'm
not sure this person knows what action
means and it was after that there's a
scene where I'm supposed to be eating a
sandwich and I don't know where the
stress came from background fighters and
sweet background players one was
supposed to bump into me and my sandwich
is supposed to go out of my hand and I
knew that these were you know genuinely
green actors and so I went out and I
said you know when you do a push just
leave it up to me like basically you can
go through and brush and i'll give it a
you know a big world and my sandwich
will drop yeah yeah yeah and i just see
as I'm talking about getting more and
more excited about this moment we never
had time to rehearse anything everything
that we shot was basically stolen on
some street that we were going to get
kicked off hi if we did another take so
I more like okay we're ready to go we
got the same group we're ready to go
guys so I see them walking down there
getting into place I'm like oh you know
good luck on this one so we hear action
and I start walking and I see this guy
coming toward me and I think he's got a
glint his eye he is so exciting to be
bamboo and I flew across the street into
a one phone booth that exists in all of
East New York I'm telling you there is
one phone booth that still exists which
now probably doesn't and my head cracked
into it and I splatted down onto the
street and and we're in I'm kind of in
the alley and it's whatever to thirty in
the morning or something and of course
i'm thinking like every actors would do
we get the shot was that funny do I have
a concussion oh I must oh I must have a
concussion because there's a lot of
people you know staring over me like
this and trying to get me into a car to
get to the hospital it was those moments
that were happening kind of almost
dangerously everything to get this movie
made it as we talked about the struggle
of it it really it's in there you know
it is in there we probably will never
experience something that is that on
that level life filmmaking again in our
life I know you hear someone who's
always been very socially conscious
there would have been some big
fundraisers here in LA most recently
President a mom and I'm wondering if you
had an opportunity to go to any of them
what they did not is actually another
fundraiser which I care deeply about I
would say more so i was at SickKids in
toronto would not happen and i do a
fundraiser for the sick kids hospital
and that was my that was my choice of
fundraising activity i wanted to james
and i go and support the hospital and
and I wanted to take Homer this year so
that he would have an opportunity to
talk to the kids after we came home last
year he was really kind of moved and i
would say confused about what that means
to have a hospital where everyone how
everyone in it is a child and everyone
is sick so we wanted to take
here and I have given money to the Obama
campaign online and now they bombard me
with like why do I do that it come up
why didn't I just walk into an office
wechter what do you think happened I
never found the first debate oh god I
not gonna get into that that's probably
them probably the most boring
conversation you can hear it on your
talk about politics I will go there I
won't do that to you just one last
question and if I may um why do you
think it is an independent film is more
willing to take a risk on darker female
characters whereas Hollywood likes the
shiny happy person um prettier girls
make more money I think what you tried I
independent film is taking risks on all
areas at not it's not just about women
are complicated women the broader your
audience the more people you have to
appeal to you know so I think it takes
an introspective person to want to go
into the theater and see the dark side
of themselves if it's represented there
we look for a reflection in those people
so if somebody's willing to take a risk
and walk through the door and go wow man
I wow some days like that I look like
that and some days I get on over to and
some days are rough that takes a
particular kind of person it does not
take a particular kind of person to
watch me with my hair crawled in my
lipstick on and a pretty lace dress and
you know if that's easy to digest that's
easy to digest and more people would
like to digest
so both are valid it's just that that's
why we have so many different media
outlets you know some people like to
hear and not see so the other radio
there are so many different ways that we
can get and participate in the in the
arts and you know fortunately I'm able
to do be able to get into some
independent film a really rough things
up a little bit and then I'm doing save
me on NBC and hopefully I'll have you
know be as lovable and accessible as I
can possibly be so everyone can giggle
with me that way to spin thank you